here we go 4 3 2 1
so Tom pop and I are sitting here and I
say did you see the fight on Saturday
night and he said the guy that got
knocked down mental health guy mental
health guy the guy got up for everyone
with mental health he said no I didn't
see the fight like I only saw I only saw
that this is how narratives work yeah
you know I mean like in this day and age
especially there's way too much
information out there right like there's
no way you could see every television
show or watch every sporting event or or
know every scandal yeah so when
something happens like the blurb that
the little summary that I have absorbed
my one buddy watched it on Instagram he
posted a thing and it was very heartfelt
that he got up for all the people of
mental health yeah and I read that and I
feel like I spent the whole thing but
you know it's funny I don't know if he
won or lost I know he got raw it was raw
yeah it was a draw okay and I don't have
a firm opinion on whether or not the
draw was justified has I only watched it
once I thought I thought that Tyson
fewer won most of the rounds except the
two that he got knocked down in Tyson's
the anti mental health guy no he's the
white guy he's the white so why the guy
that got knocked down okay and Deontay
Wilder it's his it is he's strange
and that he has like the most freaky
punching power I think I've ever seen
ever that's what I heard it's not a big
guy I mean for a heavyweight he's 212
pounds
he looks pretty big oh he's Jack yeah
but he shredded he has no fat on him
whatsoever back is where all the powers
and that's where I was his muscle is
like you see his back it's just [ __ ]
just a bundle of snakes when I saw the
clip it was like he'd knocked him out
and then like backed up and danced Tyson
got up yeah that guy look [ __ ] that guy
Wilder punches so hard and that was in
the 12th and final round that was of a
fight where he was mostly losing he was
mostly getting boxed up it was mostly
getting out boxed but then he would land
and he landed real hard and like what
was it like the 8th of the 9th something
that something like that he dropped him
but that wasn't a big knockdown right he
knocked him down we got up pretty quick
and he was he was ok
but in the 12th he [ __ ] blasted him
right he hit with the right hand and
then as he was falling and hit him with
a left hook on the chin as he was going
down like any late flat on his back with
his arms down
he looked unconscious yeah he really did
and then he was rose like Lazarus and he
looks pretty sharp when he got on his
feet he won the rest of the round
yeah he won the rest around the stung
him yeah he stung
Deontay Wilder it was crazy because of
the mental health kids yes he was doing
it for the mental health people do you
think that's really what he was thinking
when you're getting up off the canvas
I'm doing it for the kid we never doubt
him yeah I mean it was he really does
he's he's in a very unusual guy and he
donated his entire purse to charity out
of it like eight million dollars really
yeah
yeah he donated all of it to charity
holy cow yeah that's great
he's a [ __ ] really unusual guy he's
been in here he was in the podcast when
he was gearing up for the fight so I
should call him the super nice mental
health guy he's a very nice guy very
nice guys he big like giant six nine
sixth so we're sitting here you feel
like he shoes a giant but he's a super
sweetheart you're a friendly guy jeez
yeah really well-spoken
you know he's got that like heavy
travellers accent he's a traveller had
he made money before oh yeah he's a
world champion
so he's like he was a world champion
Bank mm-hmm and almost killed himself in
a Ferrari almost committed suicide he
was just headed towards the bridge he
was just gonna [ __ ] either slam into
the bridge or drive off the bridge
that was his yeah he was going 60 miles
an hour like headed towards the bridge
and changed his mind
look that's what he looked like before
he started his comeback what yeah he was
300 pounds
what's 300 plus right how much they say
he was want to say 485 yeah something
crazy because he's obviously the saint
300 kilograms so yeah times 2.2 that's
like yeah oh my God he's so he was champ
then he fell off and became that chubby
well what happened was he beat wladimir
klitschko who was a long time
heavyweight champion I mean flat McGrath
was there remember champ forever yeah
and he out boxed him like soundly out
boxed him and and beat him and then
was like now what and went into a
depression start drinking hard partying
hard a lot of cocaine and just [ __ ]
his life up just as he achieved what he
wanted to achieve
I mean he's calling it mental health you
know because of depression and all those
things but I part of me wants to say
that a lot of that is I mean I don't
know obviously I've never been inside of
his head but yeah when you're doing that
much coke and drinking that much that
has got to be a major factor in why you
feel like [ __ ] and then yeah the letdown
of this incredible achievement becoming
the heavyweight champion of the world
beating this guy who hadn't been beat in
a long time many many many years yeah
and then you know just partying too hard
and then getting into a horrible funk
and there's always I need to come back
there's always that part of it where you
know you know that you have that there
are those personalities and there's
genetics involved and he gets you into
the drugs but then the drugs start going
to work on your brain yeah and then you
know it becomes something different
becomes you know it's it's no longer
your own consciousness that's working
it's this sponge that just absorbed all
of these toxins mm-hmm who knows what's
misfiring what's happening at that point
we say that as we drink wine yes Cheers
holidays holidays whatever [ __ ] myth
I was gonna bring you some wine today
this was nice of you to open this